also at the border tonight Republican
congressman Dan Crenshaw he's a tow
southern border he was in Brownsville
Texas to see firsthand the situation on
the border
congressman Crenshaw joins us he's in
the border in McAllen Texas where we
were and also former DEA Special Agent
Derek mulches with us congressman let's
just tell everybody
I've been down there 14 times I know
what I've seen tell everybody what you
see here's the big takeaway here so that
the Rio Grande Valley is actually
responsible for about 40% of total
illegal immigration in the entire
country so it's it's a huge spot for
this now it's divided up into two spots
right there's the Brownsville area and
then there's the McAllen area the
Brownsville area has about 35 men 35
miles of pretty secure fencing it's its
border security the way that we would
like to see it it's a good mix of
Technology and secure fencing and the
McAllen area you have exactly the
opposite okay you have you have wide
open areas now so what do we see we see
about 6% of illegal apprehensions occur
in Brownsville and 94% occur in McAllen
so do walls work the answer is very
clearly yes that's exactly what we're
seeing and as we're driving over here
that you can see Mexico right behind me
so driving over here we're seeing groups
of migrants being caught as they're
crossing the border and a lot of these
have kids with them which means they
will simply be let go into the u.s.
population and what do you see Derek you
know give the experience give the
picture so people really fully
understand is this a national emergency
yes of course Shaun I mean we have a
situation I'm sorry Derek sorry I'm
sorry Derek oh so showing so basically
we had all that fentanyl seized
yesterday that could have killed 57
million people that's like half the view
is it a Super Bowl right so the American
public has to realize one kilogram could
kill 500,000 people plus if you look
like in New York today they seized
another 70 pounds of this poison that
could have killed 1520 million people
thank God our brave men and women in law
enforcement are out there on the staffed
underpaid getting all kinds of pressure
getting shot at by these people in
America so thank God President Trump is
standing up for our national security
hey Detroit asked you a question what
the Fagin kill 57 million people that
the largest haul of fentanyl that they
got just this week
what if they ever a terrorist
organization ever got a hold of that and
say wanted to lay sour food with it
absolutely what about the airplane the
seizure of 70 pounds in New York right
was done by my old unit the New York
Drug Task Force that was coming in on
planes right so it's not just coming in
on the southern border these these
billion dollar-a-year operations they
have to get their products into America
so yeah if it gets into the planes
ventilation system if it gets into
foreign supply so this is the thing the
public doesn't realize Sean this is not
a political issue this is the security
of our country and our aides let me go
back to Dan really quickly you know I
know you're strong on the issue Lindsey
Graham he's holding the line many many
Republicans will but there's always
those that have no backbone I have no
respect if the Republican Party doesn't
back the president when he uses the
military or the emergency option I don't
care which option as commander-in-chief
that's his job he swore an oath to
protect our Constitution or rule of law
and more importantly you know I'm a
member of the Homeland Security
Committee this isn't even the
president's play this this plan has been
on the books for years it has come from
border agents on the ground it comes
from experts in the Department of
Homeland Security it is walls where it
makes sense this is the places that are
men and women that are on the front
lines have been asking for this
shouldn't even be a partisan issue
this is a very it wasn't getting our men
and women and the equipment they need
just a few years ago when Obama was
president they sounded just like Trump
sad sad thank you both great reporting